all right so kristen cinema is a
democrat senator from arizona she has
upset leftists because she's not
supporting biden's agenda all the way so
i'm sure you followed some of that
don't need to to review all of it she's
not showing proper deference to to um
the leftist agenda they're mad at her so
they tracked her down at arizona state
in fact the day before this they were at
her house
uh with megaphones harassing her
and uh that didn't they felt like that
didn't get the message through so they
they they tracked her down at arizona
and they caught her in the um
in the hallway on the way into the
bathroom
and they followed her into the bathroom
to heckle her and let's listen to some
of that
okay i'll be back
that our people need in order for us to
be able to talk about what's really
happening
we need a buildback better plan right
now
we knocked on doors for you to get you
elected and just how we got you elected
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised us we
need seven million citizenship for seven
million we need the belgrave plan right
now
my name is blanca i was brought here to
the united states when i was three years
old and in 2010 my grandparents both got
deported because of sb 1070 and i'm here
because i definitely believe that we
need this pathway to citizenship my
grandfather passed away two weeks ago
and i was not able to go to mexico and
visit him because there is no pathway to
citizenship and if we have the
opportunity to pass it right now then we
need to do it because there's millions
of undocumented people just like me who
share the same story or even worse
things that happened to them because of
sb 1070.
uh so these are at least one of them is
an illegal alien
[Music]
tracking a sitting u.s senator into the
bathroom
now
you you can
only imagine the reaction if this was a
member of the uh of the squad let's say
this is alexandria casey cortez
we think about some right-wing
protesters who are upset at alexandria
casey cortez
um and they they find her in the hallway
they don't even have to follow her into
the bathroom
if they just fall down down the hallway
for ten feet
and said congresswoman can we talk to
you that would be enough right there
that would be another insurrection
and alexandria case cortez would be
doing instagram live videos about it and
crying and saying oh she almost died and
they
telling wild stories about how they came
after her with uh you know nunchucks and
and spears
and that's if they just
think about them following her into the
bathroom
and she's in the stall and they're
yelling at her
and there's a guy in there too
a guy came into the bathroom
uh now
you you can you could only imagine
imagine the response from the media
but in this case it's uh cinema who is
also a democrat
but she's being harassed by people that
are who are further to the left than she
is
and the basic rule of course is that
whoever's further to the left is always
right
and so these people are being uh are
being
defended for the most part
by lots of people on the left
and in the media
meanwhile one of these people confesses
to being an illegal immigrant
now in what other country could you get
away with that
in what other country could you
be there illegally
and then track down a government
official
on video
and confess on video to being there
illegally and then harass them in a
bathroom
and the next day you're still in the
country
what other nation maybe i should ask
what other non what non-western nation
let's see i could see that in plenty of
european countries but what in what
non-western country could you do that
can you think of a non-western country
where i could go there illegally
find one of their government officials
and start and start harassing them and
demanding that they make me legal follow
them into a bathroom
deportation will be the least of my
worries if i did that
but here you know she's the next day
she's painted as a victim
if we were a serious country
that night she would have immigrant
immigration officials at her door
carting her butt back to mexico that's
what they would be doing in a serious
country
you're here illegal illegally you're
harassing a government official in the
bathroom
and you're also recording them in a
bathroom which last time i checked
recording someone in a bathroom against
their consent is a crime
that's what a serious country would do
but we're not a serious country
and so she's allowed to get away with
this and she's also allowed to get away
with it
um she's allowed to get away with it
fundamentally because
uh the belief on the left is that if
you're not fully
on board with the agenda
then you you're not worthy of any basic
respect or dignity or anything
there's no treatment of you that could
be considered too harsh or out of bounds
you deserve all of it
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated